Maurice with a special guest yes just
chatting here with Francois Senna jetski
who is the managing director of the
wonderful Pullman hotel where this event
is being staged first of all we've been
enjoying this hotel I have to tell you
it is quite beautiful you guys did a
great job with two years of renovation
tell us your feeling about the hotels a
little bit more about this place well
actually the Puma originally the new
five-star hotel in Abidjan in a very
cost this is the one to have this order
very trendy in Abidjan and basically
we've just finished two years renovation
program and it started so we are very
happy to welcome to conscious tour
definitely absolutely a gorgeous hotel
the pool on the outside the view of the
lagoon you must be really thrilled to be
working in such a great environment well
this is actually a it's actually very
nice to work as a general manager of the
five-star hotel in Abidjan is very well
it's fantastic
it's the amazing hotel we have five-star
people five-star clients so it's very
nice very nice why is it so important
that the Grantchester event take place
here you talk about the trendiness I
heard that you guys really wanted to see
this event take place at your hotel well
this is the first competition that we
have actually in West Africa this is the
first time that the gun Chester is
actually in West Africa and it has to be
at the prom and a vision nowhere else
definitely we we have different
five-star hotel in Abidjan but I wanted
this competition to compete in in at the
promenade room definitely because this
hotel is not only a business hotel we
want to trendy hotel but we want also to
have cultural events and we've not we do
we don't have a lot of culture
even actually in a very cost nothing not
enough and basically I wanted to have
this event at the prom and Abidjan tell
me I know before we got here I was told
there was some jazz event that was here
that this that but then last night they
have the Hennessy party if I definitely
hung out good music was fantastic is
that the kind of stuff you want to do to
attract more attention to your hotel
well I want you to actor act a lot of
people definitely from Abba drama from
everywhere else we had NHC party
yesterday that's right we we were a
partnership as well with the emerges
last week we want to have different
events definitely we're not only a hotel
we are actually a place a location and
we want people to meet at the moment
every job definitely well absolutely a
great place you are doing a great job
already we're enjoying it I know the
players are as well thank you so much
for being such a great host Thank You
Francois senators key the managing
director of let me tell you what he says
five stars they mean it a great hotel